[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact man Aspinwall was a woman
who led an extraordinary life as a
sharpshooter stunt rider and trick Roper
on Buffalo Bill's Wild West Show also
known as to gun man this consummate
cowgirl with the beauty of a model and
ferocious determination accomplished a
feat that has never been matched
according to the story Bill Cody had a
strong disagreement with a rival showman
who bet Buffalo Bill that the woman
could not complete a Transcontinental
horse ride alone determined to accept
the challenge 31 year old nan set off on
September 1 1910 mounting her favorite
mare lady Ellen the intrepid cowgirl
picked up a letter from the mayor of San
Francisco addressed to the mayor of New
York City then she set out to deliver it
over the next 180 days she covered four
thousand four hundred and ninety-six
miles alone writing 25 to 30 miles a day
nan had many adventures crossing
mountains and forging rivers even
shoeing her horse herself 14 times along
the way she packed a pistol and was not
afraid to use it in one place she sent
several bullets into the door of an
establishment that was refusing her
service another time she spent a week in
a hospital after a horse stumble down
the mountainside finally on July 9 19 11
she rode into New York City delivering
her letter to City Hall becoming the
first woman to cross the United States
by horseback alone did you know the book
of Revelation pictures jesus riding
across the heavens on a white horse stay
with his friends were going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 Guinean of the
program is a good time to call in with
your bible question we are live and we
look forward to talking about the word
of god with you my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and
pastor Doug we'd like to begin the
program with prayer dear Father in
Heaven once again we thank you for the
opportunity to spend a few moments
opening up your word and studying
together I do ask your blessing upon
this program be with those who are
listening and lead us into a clearer
understanding of the Bible or we ask
this in Jesus name Amen
amen yesterday we also welcome those
joining us on Facebook across the
country and around the world we see
folks tuning in from all over the place
so if you have a Bible question and
you'd like to give us a call the number
to call is 804 six three seven two
ninety seven with your Bible question
that's how you open the program we're
talking about just an incredible feat of
going solo horseback from San Franciscan
New York City the first time a woman
ever did this in history I can just
imagine how tough that would have been
for anyone back in the nineteen eleven
early 1900s they were probably weeks
that you would travel I can just think
of the Prairie lanes without seeing
another human being
day after day after day just hoping that
you're heading in the right direction it
was probably a real epic event for one
thing you have to keep in mind there are
still states that during those years
where a woman could not ride a horse
like Amanda straddling it you had to
ride sidesaddle they actually had laws
so of course she was riding cowgirl
style and that's why some people
she said the hardest thing was finding
towns that would let her spend the night
they thought that she was you know just
some wild woman but she persevered and
it's kind of interesting when she got
into New York City and you read the
account there was a little quite a bit
of fanfare at that point and after she
delivered a letter she went to a
12-story hotel rode into the hotel lobby
with her horse rode the horse onto the
freight elevator and took it up to the
tenth or eleventh floor and rope off so
she wrote right to her room on her horse
and you got to give the horse credit
that is a long haul for one horse that's
some people were saying well she only
went 25 or 30 miles a day well for one
horse to do that day after day that is a
lot of work and so it is a remarkable
accomplishment and you know I used to
break horses
believe it or not I adopted Mustangs
from Arizona and we would break him and
try part of a kids youth program that we
did and it is frightening when you're
doing that you find horses all the way
through the Bible and you even find
horses in prophecy as some people might
be surprised to learn that in the last
book of the Bible some of the last
chapters talks about Jesus riding across
the heavens on a white horse and I'll
read that to you Matt affected mentions
several horses in this passage
revelation 19:11 now I saw heaven opened
and behold a white horse and he who sat
upon him was called faithful and true
and in righteousness he judges and makes
war his eyes were like a flame of fire
and his on his head were many crowns and
he had a name written that no one knew
except himself
and he was clothed with a robe dipped in
blood and his name was called the Word
of God and the armies in heaven clothed
in fine linen white and clean followed
him on white horses there's the horses
again and out of his mouth goes a sharp
sword that with it he should strike the
nation's and he himself will rule them
with a rod of iron
he himself treads the winepress of the
fierceness and the wrath of Almighty God
and he has on his robe and on his thigh
a name written king of kings and Lord of
lords
so this is a picture of Christ who is
the word leading the armies of heaven is
talking about the ultim
triumph of God's people so here's my
question for you is Jesus really coming
on a horse and all these other people
coming on horses and when it tells us
that chariots and horses of fire came
and picked up Elijah did the Angels
really come riding down on horses or
dorsa symbolize something in the Bible
you're asking me you know horses here
symbolized the most fearsome I guess
division of Old Testament military was
the horsemen yeah were fast they're
powerful and here Jesus described the
second coming Jesus described as coming
on a white horse is coming to bring
deliverance to his people and the Bible
speaks of the great battle of Armageddon
that takes place in the last days or the
wicked mount their attack upon God's
people and Jesus comes and delivers them
here he's pictured as King of Kings
riding on a white horse of deliverance
so yeah revelation is a symbolic book
and Jesus comes with all the angels of
having here described as coming on
horses
yeah and then you know in some places
you look it says he's coming seated on a
cloud and in Revelation 14 14 so the
horse is typically a sign of power you
know I think I think it's interesting
that when Jesus rode into Jerusalem he
drove rode on a donkey yeah a little
Colt a little donkey and now he comes as
king he's coming conquering King which
is in the ancient world when I King rode
into his home city after he conquered he
often had a white horse simple of you
know purity and power and you know you
might want to better understand prophecy
friends and we have a magazine that
deals with the prophecies of daniel and
revelation and if you call us we don't
often offer this because it's I think a
96 page color Illustrated magazine it's
a fascinating beautiful resource kind of
thing you'd want on your coffee table we
will send you one for asking but you got
a call all you'll have to do is call our
resource phone line you can ask for the
daniel and revelation magazine the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
the resource phone line and again now
always gonna have this offer available
but you can ask for the amazing facts I
Daniel and revelation magazine I'll be
happy to send it to anybody who calls
and asks one more time the number is 883
five six seven four seven well we're
ready to go to the phone lines with our
Bible questions the first call it's
evening is Stephanie in New Mexico's
definitely welcome to the program thank
you so much I've called before and I
have another question
okay okay so it's based on two
scriptures I'm about to get married in
June and I know the scripture and second
Corinthians 6:14 where it says do not be
unequally yoked together with
unbelievers for what Fellowship has
righteousness with lawlessness and what
communion has light with darkness and
then all the second Scripture why's that
first Peter 3 once or two wives likewise
be submissive to your own husbands that
even if some do not obey the word that
without a word may be one by the conduct
of their wives when they observe your
chaste conduct accompanied by fear so
the person I must marry is says he
believes in God but hasn't professed
Christ as his Savior and I don't know if
you have to do that out loud verbally in
front of someone else or not but I'm
just wondering am I being a stronger
believer than him am i unequally yoked
and if I am people kind of tell me to
hang on to the other scripture about his
conduct might be won over by mine and so
I'm just wondering what your thoughts
are on that
alright so Stephanie you are a believing
Christian and you believe the scripture
you're quoting scripture to me the
person that you're preparing to marry
you're considering marrying well it
doesn't openly profess is I think what
I'm hearing you say that Jesus is his
Lord and Savior no I've never heard him
say it well I hope you haven't sent out
invitations yet
no no I would you know what the this
verse that you're reading in Peter is
talking about you know Peter went
through the Roman world and sometimes
pagans converted to Christ and there'd
be a woman who's you know been raised to
pagan she's married to a pagan but she
accepts Jesus Peter saying well you
might reach your husband by you know
witnessing to him but they would never
recommend you went into a relationship
with someone that did not share the most
important thing in the world which is
your faith in God so when you think oh I
just gonna say and then I'll listen when
you're considering as a Christian the
criteria of the man you want to marry
you know we some say well you know I
wanted to have a sense of humor and and
want to be good-looking or I want them
to you know care about me and all the
different things you might list top of
your list as a Christian is that he
would be a committed Christian yeah if
that is not the first thing that appears
boy I wouldn't go I wouldn't even take
the second step I want to take another
date I mean I'm just being honest with
you I just see so much heartache when
people who do not share if you say my
goal in my life is to get to heaven and
to follow Christ and get closer and
closer to him and you're about to make
the strongest human link with a person
that may not be going the same direction
someone's going to get pulled against
their will yeah right so I might pray
long and hard about that you know I have
a book I can send you a free copy and
it's talked about its marriage divorce
and remarriage and you've of course the
part about marriage if you call our
resource line now pray God gives you a
courage because you know when you find
someone that's nice and loving and kind
it's really easy to forget the most
important thing that they have Jesus
first in their life then I'm gonna call
if you'd like to get that free resource
that book is called marriage divorce and
remarriage just call 883 five six seven
four seven and as for the book this is
for anyone then I'm gonna call these
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven as for the book on marriage
thank you for your call Stephanie our
next caller is Kim listening from not
quite sure we camps listening
from that came out there talk to you
anyway hello all right thanks for
calling thanks for calling yeah if I am
saying pastor duck I have a quick
question on do we still need to keep the
10 commandments because I have a pastor
that says we don't need to keep the Ten
Commandment that's on the Old Testament
Jesus kept it all to us so you know we
don't need to keep the commandments
anymore
well young man came to Jesus and he's a
good master what things should what
should I do that I might inherit eternal
life and I think this is Mark chapter 10
and it's actually in three Gospels and
Jesus said why do you call me good
no one is good but God if you would
enter into life keep the commandments
said which ones Jesus begins to recite
the ten commandments to him and you can
find a number of places in the New
Testament where it talks about the
commandments and then it references the
Ten Commandments yeah the verse is
referring to you can read about in
Matthew chapter 19 verse 29 mark 10
verse 17 Luke Tang 25 and yes also
refers a little bit in Luke 18 so yeah
Jesus said if you love me keep my
Commandments and you know I think well
what Commandments are those well it
would start with and a loving God covers
the first four commandments if you love
God you don't worship other gods you
don't use his name in vain etc if you
love your fellow man you don't lie to
them you don't kill them you don't steal
them that covers the last six
commandments and so loving God and
loving your fellow man are the two
principles that encompass the 10
commandments but of course a believers
gonna want to keep the Ten Commandments
which ones would be okay to break is it
okay for a believer to lie or to steal
or to kill or to covet so yeah so yeah
the moral law is just it's a
foundational truth for all believers he
also says that you just kept the Ten
Commandments because he's conceived by
yeah yeah because we are carnal or like
nature's on
well but you know the whole idea of
being saved as he saves us from
disobedience so we can't obey you know
Bible says when you're converted old
things are passed away all things are
made new John tells us in his letter if
we say we love him and keep not his
Commandments were a liar now that's
pretty clear so I know I hear pastors
every now and then saying Jesus kept the
law for us so we don't have to but to me
that is that's just well the old sailors
used to call it scuttlebutt me
it's like bilge water it's that's
totally not true jesus said whosoever
shall break the least of these
Commandments is in Matthew chapter five
I think 17 through 19 whoever will break
the least of these Commandments and
teach men so he's spoken of as least in
the kingdom of heaven but whoever will
do and teach them will be called great
in the kingdom of heaven and so yeah
Jesus said think not that I've come to
destroy the law the idea that Jesus came
to destroy the law is antithetical to
everything he died for you know you
mentioned that verse in 1st John chapter
5 if I read a couple more verses it's so
clear in 1st John chapter 5 verse 3 for
this is the love of God that we keep his
Commandments and that his commandments
are not burdensome for whatever is born
of God overcomes the world and this is
the victory that overcomes the world
even our faith who is he who overcomes
the world but he who believes in Jesus
as the Son of God so there is pretty
clear that it's the will of God it's the
love of God that we keep his
Commandments how do we keep his
Commandments through faith in Jesus yeah
you know what I'd like to do if it's
okay with you and is it uh yeah we'll
send you a really good study that's full
of scripture on this and it's called
written in stone and it's a study on
what the Bible new and old testament
says about the law and how a Christian
saved by grace relates to that and I
know you'll be blessed the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
you can answer the study guide called
written in stone I'm happy to send this
to you cam or anybody who calls and asks
a next quarter that we have enjoy
listening from Kansas City joy welcome
to the program thank you I wanted to ask
you both about
how many types of angels are there and
one of their ministry that's a great
question I have to tell you I don't know
now I can tell you what the Bible says
there are different kinds of angels and
they're probably different levels and
different ranks for lack of a better
word of angels that Bible speaks of
cherubim and Seraphim and Holy Ones and
you know sometimes it uses the same word
to describe these a ministering spirits
is another term that's used in Hebrews
but there's a whole realm Paul calls
them principalities and powers in
heavenly places there is a whole realm
of ministering spirits around the throne
of God you have the two angels that are
the covering cherub by the throne of God
there in Isaiah chapter six they cry
holy holy holy by the throne that's the
two angels on the ark were a symbol of
them and you know God Gabriel he seems
to be a high-ranking angel that brings
messages Jesus talks about protecting we
call him guardian angels he talks about
the children he says even their angels
do behold the face of my father in
heaven this never uses the word guardian
angels but there are verses that say
he'll give his angels charge over you to
keep you in all your ways and in other
verses the angel of the lord encamps
round about those that fear him so it's
a it's a big study I'm sure that there's
a lot about angels we don't know but we
don't know the different rankings but it
seems there's different levels the
Archangel is actually that's probably
one of the most misunderstood terms the
Archangel is not an angel like a cherub
the Archangel is a term that's often
used to refer to Jesus before his
incarnation now Jesus is not an angel
Jesus is the eternal son of God he's not
created the word angel means messenger
matter of fact even King David is
sometimes called an angel he's not a
cherubim he doesn't have wings but
Michael means who is as God and when you
read in 1st Thessalonians chapter 4
about the second coming
says the Lord Himself will descend from
heaven with a shout with the voice of
the Archangel the Lord with the voice of
the Archangel and when this Archangel
appears that Joshua Joshua is told to
take his shoes off his ground because
off his feet cuz it's holy ground so
Michael is a different category but you
know what we might do that's a good that
gives me a good idea why don't we send
you our free book on Michael the
Archangel I was gonna suggest that the
number to call he's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
answer the book called who is Michael
the Archangel I think it's about not
only the Archangel but it talks about
some of the other angels that we read
about in the Bible again the number is
885 six seven four seven asked for the
book called who is Michael the Archangel
a next caller that we have is calling
from Wisconsin believe it's Jean Jean
welcome to the program hey thank you
good evening you guys nice to talk to
you again thank you for calling
well thanks dog quick question for you
in the garden when Jesus is praying to
the Father I'm a little confused Jesus
is God incarnate on earth correct and
he's praying he's praying until blood
mixes with his sweat to the Father can
you explain that I'm I'm a little
confused that he's praying to himself
there well Jesus and of course not only
in the Garden of Gethsemane but many
times Jesus prayed sometimes he spent
entire nights in prayer because when
Christ came to earth and that verse in
Philippians he made himself of no
reputation pastor Ross when Jesus came
to earth he set aside obviously a
dimension of his divinity that's why on
the cross you know he's thirsty and he's
begging for a drink that's why he falls
asleep in a boat during a storm because
he's exhausted like a human he took on
human form and so he still was a hundred
percent God in his in his power but he
never used that power except as we can
so Christ came as our example
he prayed as an example to us that we
need to pray and not only in the Garden
of Gethsemane but you know he prays
in mr. John 17 is a beautiful prayer he
prays of the tomb of Lazarus for the
resurrection Jesus in the Lord's Prayer
he tells the disciples how to pray so
Christ always prayed to the Father as an
example on how we approach the father
the virtue referring to his Philippians
chapter 2 verse 7 where it talks about
Jesus when he came to the earth made
himself of no reputation taking the form
of a bondservant coming in the likeness
of men
yea Jesus upon himself humanity laid
aside his divinity and you know he had
asked of the father even as we need to
ask we have that book that Joe Cruz
wrote it's great called Christ's human
nature and maybe we could send you a
free copy of that and it's got a lot of
scripture on this question all right you
just call 4s for it yes the number to
call 808 three five six seven four seven
you can ask to the book called Christ
human nature will be happy to send this
to anybody who calls and asks next color
that we have is let's see we've got
Stephen Stephen welcome to the program
thank you very much I appreciate taking
my call listener first-time caller
I have a question it's referring to
Exodus chapter xxi verse 13 the Ten
Commandments says thou shalt not kill
and then if it skipped over to Genesis
22 you refer him to Abraham and Isaac
and here's where my question is Isaac
stretched out four worth reading verse
10 his hand and took a knife to slay him
now I know that God commanded him to
kill his son but in his heart when he
raised a knife to slay his son it
appears that he you know broke the ten
commandments but obeying God's Word at
the same time I'm confused can you
clarify yeah first of all the
commandment in Exodus 20:13 technically
it reads and I'm reading it right now
from the New King James Version thou
shalt not murder so first of all murder
is a little different from correct yeah
but you do have a point that you know
when God says
that's what not murder and then he tells
Abraham take your son and offer him as a
sacrifice when God had always said that
he didn't believe that pagans should
offer human sacrifice god of course has
the power to preempt his own law because
the law it comes from him
he wouldn't allow Abraham to do it so he
never did it was really a test do you
love me enough that you would do it and
would you give your greatest gift would
you put everything on the altar for me
and Abraham said yes I would well God
stopped him he wouldn't let him go
through with that but you know that is
something of a conundrum and pastor ross
is a thought here yeah just a couple
quick things first of all you know you
reading New Testament what it says about
it and says abraham believed that god
would raise him from the dead
that's right Hebrews 11 there was
evidence that this was a sacrifice and
Isaac participated in that he was a
willing sacrifice his father didn't
interested he trusted in God as his
father did and they were in agreement
saying well if this is what God asked
God as a purpose he as a plan let's
trust in him so the whole context of
that was quite different than if someone
were to get angry with somebody else and
take their life mm-hmm it was a
sacrifice and they would trust in God
that somehow he would work it out he had
a plan for them yeah and right and
that's and that's the reason why I had
so much the question because I knew that
the killing was actually through
obedience in love
it wasn't the angry murder it wasn't yet
it was a premeditated and a know Abraham
begg'd days did you know or is it really
you God telling me to do something that
has never ever happened in history and
that's what caught my attention
it's a beautiful analogy that stories
one of the great analogies of the
sacrifice of Jesus in that they went
three and a half days to the mountain
and they the wood is placed on Isaac's
back just as a cross was placed on Jesus
back Isaac is a willing sacrifice as
Jesus was a willing sacrifice Isaac in
figure and I think this is also in
Hebrews 11 in Figure Isaac experiences a
resurrection he was all tied up and
ready to die and he
untighten is free so you
and it's interesting three and a half
days to the place of sacrifice Jesus
preaches three and a half years then
finally the replacement for Isaac is
they find a ram caught by his horns in a
thicket and the word thicket there means
a thorn bush and so you've got a ram
with a crown of thorns and just the
whole story is sort of seeping with the
gospel and so God allowed this drama to
transpire to be a lesson to all future
ages in fact when Jesus said before
Abraham was I am and they said how could
you say you knew father Abraham because
you're not even 50 years old Jesus said
Abraham longed to see my day and he saw
it when Abraham saw Jesus day was when
he offered his son on the mountain don't
go very far friends we're just going to
take our halftime break
/ drink of water we've got more Bible
questions coming if you want to call in
with your question 804 6 3 7 297 have an
important announcement when you come
back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm in six days God created
the heavens and the earth for thousands
of years man has worshiped God on the
seventh day of the week now each week
millions of people worship on the first
day what happened why did God create a
day of rest does it really matter what
day we worship who is behind this great
shift discover the truth behind God's
law and how it was changed visit Sabbath
truth calm if you've missed any of our
amazing facts programs visit our website
at amazing facts org there you'll find
an archive of all our television and
radio programs including amazing facts
presents one location so many
possibilities amazing facts org can't
get enough amazing facts Bible study you
don't have to wait until next week to
enjoy more truth filled programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aft vor G at aft vor G you can enjoy
video and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge 24
hours a day seven days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aft vor G
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 end will be
answered just try it again
and I want to welcome our friends who
are listening also on Facebook we have
an important announcement for something
that's coming before our next broadcast
on what they call Good Friday next
Friday March 30 7:00 p.m. there is
another radio host who answers a Bible
question Steve Greg of the narrow paths
and we're going to be doing a debate
friendly discussion talking about the
Sabbath and the New Covenant and it'll
be on my Facebook page it'll be on the
amazing facts page on amazing facts TV
on the narrow path radio broadcasts the
channel and it should be a very
interesting discussion of these it's
going to be 90 minutes we're gonna take
turns and give the pro in the con on
whether or not we do need to keep the
Ten Commandments once we're saved so
you'll want to plan on tuning in to that
you can find out more about that just
going to the amazing facts for website
which is simply amazing facts dot o-r-g
and my name is doug batchelor
my name is John Ross and pass today we
ready to go back to the phone lines we
have Chris listening in Vancouver Chris
welcome to the program hello hey thank
you for waiting in your question my
question is I'm a parent my son goes to
a public school we're not we're not able
to send them to a Christian school and
with Christian schools closing down and
and our government in Canada kind of
introducing laws that go against
Christianity how do we
is there any biblical evidence or advice
that we should follow to contradict
what's going on yes in Deuteronomy
chapter 6 Moses said these words I
command you this they shall be in your
heart and he talks about Deuteronomy 5
is the Ten Commandments said you shall
teach them to your children when you lay
down when you rise up when you go out
and when you come in and they shall be
written on your hand between your eyes
and on your doorposts you need to
compensate for what the kids are going
to hear in school both from the teachers
and sometimes from unconverted friends
and not every parent can homeschool I
know in some countries they don't allow
that and some families work in
situations don't allow it and and not
every parent is actually equipped to be
a homeschool teacher some are better
equipped than others but all parents
should be able to teach their children
the Word of God and just so saturate
them with it that's why Moses said when
you lay down evening worship with your
kids when you rise up morning worship
with your kids even if it's short have
prayer with them read a verse and you
help them memorize some of the important
principles so when they encounter the
false things remind your kids you are
missionaries just like missionary
families used to go into the jungles
where people ran around naked and did
all kinds of crazy things those
missionaries would have to teach their
kids yes the the pagans around you are
going to do some
crazy things because they're pagans and
they understood they were missionaries
so teach your kids when they go into the
jungle of a public school they're a
missionary okay that makes sense
that does make sense that actually makes
a lot of sense I could and it's tough I
know I know what the laws are you
talking about and there's certain
programs we can't air in Canada because
if they say it's not loving a lot of
people here don't want to actually talk
about issues that are actually we're
actually facing in the severity that
they actually you know that they're
becoming criminal now wait you can
criminally put be put in jail for
teaching your children against these
principles I know and there is a very
militant now I'm in North America so I
can still say this but there is a very
militant homosexual lobby in some of
these countries where in England and in
Canada and some places that if you speak
against it because the Bible does they
call it hate speech and you got to be
very careful what you say because you're
right pastors and different folks are
being put in jail and they will not
tolerate another point of view if you
have a different point of view you've
lost that freedom in some states some
countries so we'll pray God gives you
wisdom and appreciate your call Chris we
do have a book will send you called
culture in the Christian and I'm going
to call these eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and again you
can ask for the book called culture and
the Christian next for the brave is Nick
listening from college Dale Tennessee
Nick welcome to the program hey thanks
for having me pastor Doug so my question
is what is the Trinity and why does it
matter well I'll start with the second
half of that why does it matter
I think anything revealed in the Word of
God about God says something about the
greatness of God it matters because it
tells us about his exalted position and
his holiness if you know the Trinity of
course believes that not only God the
Father is eternal is you know
all-knowing and he's all-powerful it
tells us God the
Sun is eternal all-knowing and
all-powerful and some people believe
Jesus is a creation of the Father that
God just sort of promoted him to be a
God but he was created at one point that
I think that I think undermines the
sacrifice of God the Father and the son
it it's almost like God creates somebody
to be a sacrifice well that's you know
that's easy for you to do but if God
himself
if the creator is willing to die to
redeem the creation it tells us
something different about God so
understanding that I think is important
and then also the you know the
omnipotence of God the spirit and the
omnipresence of God the spirit as well
so I think that the teachings do matter
I think there are gonna be some people
in heaven that maybe misunderstood this
so you know I want to be careful not to
make it sound like you can't be saved if
you don't understand the Trinity yeah
one other illustration of water how some
say that you can use water and the three
separate states to illustrate the
Trinity well whenever you you know
resort and I've heard people use an egg
they say you know you've got a shell
you've got the yolk you've got the white
and it's all one thing and people say
water is one thing the problem with the
water illustration is it lends towards
what they call modalism meaning that God
sometimes manifests himself as the son
and sometimes he manifests himself as a
father and sometimes as a spirit that
he's just one he's one God that kind of
morphs in different ways and we don't
believe that we believe there's separate
distinct persons because of the baptism
of Jesus you've got God the Father
speaks in heaven God the son is in the
water God the Spirit is coming down
between the two there are three
different persons at the same time in
three different places so we believe in
three unique persons when God is on when
Jesus is on earth praying to the Father
he's not talking to himself it's talking
to another distinct being
you know we have a book called the
Trinity is a biblical and deals with the
subject gives a lot of good Bible verses
and we'll be happy to send this to you
NIC or anybody wanting to learn more
about the subject and I'm gonna call
these eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called the Trinity is it biblical
one more time that's 808 three five six
seven four seven the next call is James
listening in Orlando Florida James
welcome to the program
hi James thank you for calling hey um I
have a question about angels okay
and do fallen angels
there's a Verdura star in the Bible
where Jesus comes in contact with
someone who is demon possessed and he
casts them out into a herd of pigs mark
chapter 5 yeah so I'm just curious when
and not necessarily specific to that
incidence in the Bible but in just in
general demon possession when when you
hear stories about you in possession
does that mean that fallen angels are
literally inside the person inside the
body what does that just mean that
they're like controlling their mind or
something well it's a good question I
don't know that the angels you know come
in and totally possess every fiber of
the body like some kind of ghost
they definitely possess the mind or
influence the mind of the person that's
where the devil has his guy God doesn't
possess our foot he doesn't you know
possess our elbow a person can lose
their foot and still be filled with the
Holy Spirit God possesses our minds and
the devil will do that it was the devil
that spoke through a serpent in the
Garden of Eden and we know the devil can
fill pigs as they did there and
sometimes I thought my neighbors had a
demon-possessed dog that parked all
night but but and God can speak through
a donkey so you know thinking yeah I've
heard stories and some churches where
the preacher will put their hand on
somebody and they would collapse of the
floor shaking out of their mouths
becomes the voice of a demon so just oh
I just always will always
wondered if it was actually inside their
body or just like a mind control kind of
thing yeah the demons actual possess the
mind because in that story in mark
chapter 5 when the demon talks to Jesus
he says our name is a legion because
there's many of us well you don't fit
2,000 Devils and that's a Roman legion
in one person but they're there that
many that were manipulating his mind and
it is true I've I've met people that you
know we're demon-possessed and sometimes
the devil speak through them what a
person loses their temper and they get
angry the devil can inspire them to say
things that are mean and cutting they
may not be totally possessed but they're
influenced I know time is limited so I
want to sneak in one more question about
angels in Genesis the breath of life
plus the dust of the earth is the two
ingredients for a living soul but what
about angels what kind of living soul
does an angel half because I imagine
they don't have the dust of the earth
just the breath of life
well now I'm delving a little bit into
things I don't understand
you know Paul calls them principalities
and powers they're ministering spirits
they do not age like we do Gabriel
appears to Daniel five hundred years
later more than that he appears to Mary
and he has an aged so they're
ministering spirits that are created
humans are born okay but you wouldn't
call him like a soul right no not like a
human you know they're very different
we're made in the image of God there's a
difference but then the Bible says
people are made a little lower than the
Angels maybe meaning less physical power
because they are the soldiers of God so
yeah there's some mysteries there we
don't understand I need to write a book
about angels because we get a lot of
questions on that hey thank you very
much we're gonna move on to the next
caller
next what are they we have is she'll be
listening from Kentucky she'll be
welcome to the program yeah thank you
guys
my question was I wanted to know the
difference between the new and the Old
Covenant and all that can feet on that
I've got the law the first part
laws of love and liberty but I don't
really fully understand it all right
well yeah sometimes we talked about the
Old Testament the New Testament the word
Testament and covenant are the same you
first find the New Covenant in the Old
Testament it's in Jeremiah 31:31 where
he says a new covenant will I make with
the house of Israel after those days now
the Old Covenant God made with Israel
after the Ten Commandments were orally
spoken they said all the Lord has said
we will do so God said here's my law the
people said we will keep your law we
will be your people God says all right
I'm going to give you a written
transcript and you know why God is
getting the written transcript Moses is
picking it up they make a golden calf
and they break all the commandments and
so you read in Hebrews it says that the
New Covenant is based on better promises
the promise of the people to keep God's
law failed the New Covenant is based on
the promise of God God says I will write
my law in their hearts through the power
of the Spirit and through the power of
love when we see Jesus death for us we
want to keep his law because we love Him
and so the New Covenant is the same law
but it's written on the heart and we
want to observe it because of love so
you've got the Ten Commandments in both
the old and the New Covenant what you
have is better promises and God says
he'll write in on our hearts that's a
very simple way but I you know I've got
a study I'll send you that talks about
why the Old Covenant failed
it's a booklet by Joe Cruz it's a great
little book why the Old Covenant failed
and we'll send you a free copy of that
and it's got all the verses on that okay
alright hey thanks so much for your call
all right the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can answer the book why the
Old Covenant failed one more time that
number is 885 six seven four seven we
have Roberta listening from South
Carolina
Roberta welcome to the program hello
they might have Meudon sometimes they're
waiting patiently
we'll try Roberta once Roberta twice
alright we'll put you on hold
check again later Abigail listening
Sonora California alright thank you for
calling and your question my question is
why did God accepted Abel's offering but
did not accept Cain's offering alright
very good in the beginning when man
sinned you remember Adam and Eve when
they first sinned they're the robes of
light kind of went out and they saw they
were naked and they went and tried to
make some aprons out of fig leaves well
leaf clothing doesn't work very well and
lasts very long and it says God gave
them robes of skin now in order for us
to wear leather something has to die and
so this is when God told them that
someday his son would come like the Lamb
of God and die for their sins and so
they would sacrifice lambs from time to
time as a symbol of the blood of Jesus
that would wash away our sin so Abel did
what God told him he brought a lamb to
sacrifice for a sin but Cain thought
that was kind of mean and messy and he
said I don't want to obey God I'm gonna
bring fruit from my garden and God said
no you can't be forgiven by offering
apple juice you can only be forgiven by
offering the blood of the Lamb a life
has to be lost for you to be saved and
so King got upset that his idea was not
accepted that his brother was right and
he was wrong and he ultimately killed
his own brother so it's only by the the
sacrifice of a life that our lives could
be saved and forgiven and those lambs
that died don't really save us it's a
symbol for Jesus the Lamb of God that
saves us God's son does that make sense
Wow well that's a deep question we
appreciate your calling to ask that and
I'm trying to think what we can send a
bee that she would enjoy I wonder if
you'd like our comic book on the second
coming of Jesus yeah that right that's
right
we have one on dinosaurs we have one on
the Second Coming we have one on what
happens when you die or you're left to
do is just call an ass for it then I'm
gonna call these eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for how old are you a B nine oh
yeah you'll enjoy this you know what
even more I think you'd enjoy the
amazing instead of lessons that's
getting there if you call and ask for
that we'll be happy to send that to you
as well the number again 808 three five
six seven four seven ask for the amazing
adventure lessons and we'll try and get
that out to you I mix color that we have
is Robert listening from college place
Washington Robert welcome to the program
thank you
good evening evening thank you for
calling yes I have a question regarding
Genesis 1:14 some people I understand
say that has to do with the lunar
Sabbath let there be lights in the vault
of the sky to separate the day from the
night and let them serve as signs to
mark sacred times some versions say so
are we supposed to celebrate the lunar
Sabbath or the or the weekly Sabbath
they're both well the the signs and the
seasons this is chapter one there's no
sin all of the ceremonial Sabbath's came
as a result of sin to point to Jesus
this is talking about a time when there
was no sin everything was perfect and
the signs and the seasons had to do with
the garden and planting we know that the
seasons do affect plants some things
only flower during the Moon and Adam and
Eve in the garden they were to dress in
to keep Adam and Eve were
horticulturists by God's design and so
I'm sure the seasons had something to do
with the seasons of the the garden and
the seasons of the earth it didn't have
to do with sacrifices and feast days
because there was no sin yet so when
people say to mark sacred time says
that's a that's a wrong translation
caning well marking you mean if for
chapter one absolutely it's not talking
about it's not talking about Jewish
feasts
because all the Jewish feasts had to do
with the sacrificial system and they
were the result of sin and they did not
appear until after the Exodus
these are seasons that have to do with
you notice it says right before that all
the different kinds of trees that yield
fruit so it's talking about an
agricultural signs and seasons you know
you've heard of a farmer as a Hallman AK
that talks about you know when to plant
your Tomatoes based upon the seasons mmm
there are there are things that happen
astronomically that have to do with
agriculture and tides and even before
sin that was probably true but it had
nothing to do with the ceremonial
sacrifices and the feast days of Israel
that came 2,000 years later okay
all right well thank you all right thank
you appreciate that good question we're
gonna try and get Roberto back the cold
drop just a little earlier Roberto
welcome to the program hi pastor Doug
and Pastor Sean thank you for taking my
call yeah thanks for your patience my
question is on John 14:15 and what is
the Greek word for love in that text and
how do we know that our thoughts and our
heart or our feelings in our heart for
God are the love is the right type of
love that he wants us to have for him um
all right let me I'm looking this up
right now I just want to make sure I
give you an accurate answer the word
love here is agape this is one of the
examples where agape is talking about
our I got pale is talking about a
selfless love it's the pure love it's
not like Philadelphia which is a
brotherly love or folios it's not
talking about a story gay it's not
talking about eros which was more of
that's where you get the word erotic it
was more of a romantic love and so the
second part of your question how do we
know if the thought of love that we have
in our heart is the right type of love
that God wants us to have for example I
pray to God and
ask him to help me to love him the way
he wants me to and the type of feelings
that I have in my heart are just a deep
thankfulness and a wanting to serve him
out of thankfulness you know you're
asking one of the most important
questions if more believers would talk
about how we could love better
everything else would fall into place
our obedience our passion for souls all
of that if we had loved God better and
so I pray that God just gives me his
love he gives me his spirit it's a
selfless love it's a love that that says
you know not what's in it for me but
lord I want I want to love you and put
you first you know I think the key is in
you asked what type of love is described
in the verse the agape love is the
self-sacrificing love that we see
demonstrated in the life of Christ now
of ourselves we can't generate that kind
of love but as we spend time in
communion with God his love is implanted
into our hearts of course it takes time
the Bible speaks of our relationship
growing we grow in grace so it's a
day-by-day experience but that can't
occur if we're not centering our heart
and our mind on Christ and talking to
him
communicating with him it says in first
John 4:19 we love him because he first
loved us so the way to increase our love
for him is by beholding his love for us
and this was what John also says in
first John 3 behold what manner of love
the father has bestowed on us so as we
behold the love of God at the cross
through his life is sacrificed it then
inspires love for us and I think all of
us have been touched to move when
someone does something selfless as we
behold it it it does something in us so
that's the key right there and I hope
that helps a little bit hey thank you
very much for your question Roberta and
your persistence we're gonna see if we
get a couple more we got Benedicta from
Bronx New York
hi all right thank you for waiting
thank you so much for taking my call I
just want to find out what's girl's
opinion about gambling Christians
gambling like you know playing lottery
or this dollar bill yes always and then
I have two questions these 24 elders in
the book of Revelation where they come
from
all right right we've probably got time
for just the one I see we got like it
was two minutes late so let me just do a
work on gambling real quick and you
could maybe find out more about the 24
elders at our website anything that is
addicting we probably should avoid and
we know some people get addicted to
gambling the idea of getting money
quickly or getting a lot of money
rapidly Solomon says he that will make
haste to be rich will not be innocent
and so you know the gamble there at the
cross for Jesus and that wasn't good he
died they gambled for Jonah and he got
tossed overboard gambling doesn't have a
real good record in the Bible the the
idea when you gamble usually it's the
house that wins and people are
impoverished there's just a few rich
people that own the casinos that they
make money it's often been associated
with organized crime and government
which are almost one of the same or
thing so hey I apologize if we can't get
more of your question but don't give up
on us Benedicta give us a call next week
and we'll try and deal with that 24
Eldar question before we sign off
friends I want to remind you that next
Friday evening 7 p.m. don't forget to
tune in live you can listen to the
amazing facts website a-f-t-v are those
of you watching right here on the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page we're going to
be streaming a debate between myself and
Steve Gregg both have radio programs and
where we deal with Bible questions we're
gonna talk about in a friendly way the
Sabbath Christians and the New Covenant
and be taking questions on the Facebook
page as well what am I forgetting
oh yeah if you like this program and you
want to keep us on the air you know
we're 100% supported by our listeners
friends we'd love to hear from you
you can just go to the amazing facts
page and click donate you can also do it
through our app
amazing facts dot o-r-g godless thank
you for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
Wham you're hit with something new your
marriage your job your health you could
look to the stars but they don't have
the answers but this does the prophecy
Study Bible by amazing facts
it's 27 personal study guides leave you
on a life-changing journey get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore com can't get enough amazing
facts Bible study you don't have to wait
until next week to enjoy more truth
filled programming visit the amazing
facts media library at aft vor G at aft
vor G you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word visit our web
site at WWF AG 0 RG and sign up for our
free Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore calm which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at $887
macing facto rg4 life-changing christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm